I have been talking about a lot and I
feel like skin topics are so popular
today because so many people deal with
bad skin and I've never dealt with bad
skin before and I was really lucky
growing up to have those little
blemishes here and there but I truly
experienced what girls experience with
cystic acne and scarring and things like
that these last few months and I will
tell you I understand you when you're
crying in your car like you don't want
to leave your house you feel so insecure
it is truly like the hardest thing to do
there's actually nothing that makes your
confidence plum
than having it's like you can't even
cover it with makeup cuz you still see
the texture and everything but as you
can see I've cleared it and I will say
this I was really determined to do my
research and figure out holistic ways
and healthy ways to get it out without
having to take any medicine and I
figured it out because look at my skin
it's gone not going crazy it's so crazy
and no one believed me